hey youtubers is Charlie so I hope
you've all had a chance to watch the
season 4 finale a couple more times
since it aired but since we're heading
into the hiatus now I wanted to start my
bonus videos off with just a look at my
favorite moments from season 4 as a
whole so a lot of you have been asking
for some full-on spoilery videos for
season 5 so I'll have an announcement
for that after my list so be sure to
stick around since this video is all
about season four moments hopefully
you've had a chance to see the episodes
but just in case spoiler warning for
season four so here we go number 10 the
reforging of ice I was so happy they
decided to use this to open the season
it's so hot I in hypnotic they even
played rains of castamere softly in the
background while it was happening
I know a lot of you guys flipped out
whenever they buried widows wail with
Joffrey but at least we still have
keeper roaming around the Vale with
Brienne I remember after we met barrack
and Thoros people started to talk more
and more about resurrection and
reanimation or at least reanimation in
terms of the White Walkers and
characters coming back like secretly
everyone was trying to do the mental
math on Ned Stark being able to return
and reclaim ice and take revenge on
everyone either as a white or someone
with crazy red god magic but whenever
you see ice get melted down it's like
all your hopes get melted down with it
the only way anyone would be able to
restore it now would be to dig up
Joffrey's corpse and hunt down Brienne
not that reforging ice would restore
House Stark or Winterfell in any way but
it's just one of those secret wishes
that in your fandom brain you hope would
come to pass like Ned Stark would return
and just take revenge on everyone my
sympathies the book readers to let me
know if you had that thing where you
read about this a long long time ago in
the books and just forgot about it until
you saw it on screen it's almost like
sometimes on the show I feel like I'm
learning about things all over again
just because it's been so long since I
read it in the books I know a lot of you
guys have been reading the books since
the show started which is amazing I'm so
happy this show has people reading more
but book 3 was published in 2000 which
is like 14 years ago so a lot of times I
find I have to reread stuff before the
season starts just for context it also
happens whenever new books are published
so when wins a winner gets published I'm
probably gonna have to reread Dance with
Dragons just to remember what happened
onto number 9 shiny new dragons the
Dragons in general this year were
amazing as it's
did that was one of the biggest effects
they were talking about during season
three so of course they had to top
themselves for season four and make the
Dragons look that much cooler if you
wondered why we did not see them that
much it's just because they're so
expensive to do digital effects are
really expensive I'm looking forward to
the day when a fully digital creature
can be nominated for a Best Performance
the best dragon actor of course is
Benedict Cumberbatch in desolation of
Smaug Peter Jackson full-on mow capped
his performance so the dragon was much
closer to being a real-life actor I
don't think the Dragons on Game of
Thrones are mocap just because they
don't speak words but drogon was a great
actor this season he was like a big dog
or like a tiger that was just
domesticated like an animal that you
could walk up and pet but dangerous
enough that he could shred you by
accident if he wanted to play I feel
like two of the biggest dragon questions
in the Phantom are one you know could
brand ever warg a dragon and two what is
the particulars of the psychic link that
the Targaryen have with the Dragons
george RR martin has never given a
definitive answer about working he's
only said there's no precedent no one in
history has ever tried to work a dragon
or been recorded trying to do it and he
hasn't gotten far enough into the books
to explain the minutiae of Targaryen
dragon bonding if you do want to read a
book that goes into that a little bit
more you should read the princess in the
Queen it's a short story that's part of
that dangerous women anthology it deals
with the dance of the Dragons it's one
of the many Targaryen civil wars that
happen in history so if you want to read
more about dragons on Game of Thrones
that would be a good place to start even
though it takes George our Martin a long
time to write those sequel novels like
wins a winner he does write a lot of
bonus content like dance of the Dragons
on to number eight the purple wedding
and Joffrey's death as amazing as this
was it was no red wedding and Joffrey's
death wasn't even the biggest thing I
saw you guys talking about after the
episode it was actually the dwarf
jousting that was like the biggest
question I got dad and penny just
because she had a lot of emotional
scenes in the book with Tyrion I really
watched the episode a couple times and
couldn't find any references to penny
but I do feel like the dwarf jousting
completely lived up to expectations it
was ridiculous I think if he felt
excited about it and then immediately
shameful for being excited you were
right where george RR martin wanted you
to be there were actually a lot of times
in the season where I found myself
cheering and really awful stuff
on-screen mostly
because it's fun to see stuff from the
books and then immediately you know you
processed the moment and think oh this
is really bad I'm a terrible person for
cheering right now and then suddenly
Joffrey dies and you don't feel ashamed
about cheering anymore it's not
something I mentioned a lot but one of
the things I love most about the show is
the way it makes you feel really excited
for really terrible terrible things
things like dwarf jousting Tyrion
murdering people White Walkers the list
just goes on and on but number seven
Jaime and Cersei and Baelor except over
your own son's dead body how could you
this was an infamous book moment that
became much more controversial on the
show at the end of the day I think what
they intended to do with it and what the
audience saw were two different things I
was disturbed by what played out
on-screen but because I kind of knew
what was coming in advance I wasn't
quite as outraged as people who only
watch the show the thing that really
stands out to me aside from the actual
act of the sex is the way Jaime reacts
when people call him out as the father
of Circe's children the only time I've
ever seen him acknowledge it in an
obvious way is when Tyrion called him
out right after he was thrown in prison
after Joffrey died whenever Cersei
called it out as being like our baby boy
is dead it seemed like Jaime just kind
of mentally let it pass right through
his brain almost like he was mentally
blocking the thought as he was later in
the finale whenever Cersei said she told
Tywin what they'd been doing
I don't think Jaime wants to deny that
search these children are his I
definitely think he understands it I
think he's more of like I've changed the
conversation kind of person like he's
like let's not confirm or deny let's
just talk about something else I'm
interested to see if season five does
any fatherly tama and Jaime scenes they
only really started giving a lot of
scenes to Tom and after Joffrey died
this season so it'll be interesting to
see what the show decides to do on to
number six Daario takes the champion of
marine pissing in the dust
notwithstanding this was a pretty
medicine the really obvious homage I saw
was the Raiders of the Ark takedown but
the biggest easter egg was something
that I didn't learn about till much
later the champion of marine is
basically shouting Monty Python insults
whenever he rides out of the gates it
was this really elaborate joke that DB
Weiss thought of he's a huge Monty
Python fan so he had the champion shot
the Frenchman's insults from Holy Grail
but because they're really strict about
die Jetix speech the person who created
the Valyrian language translated the
insults into low Valyrian so that it
could be
George RR Martin's World whenever miss
and I translated it she translated it as
something different so you would have
only known about the Monty Python
insults if you spoke low valyrian and if
you can do that you are amazing and
deserve a high five because that's just
awesome number five
sir pounce makes a rare appearance as
much as the show changes things from the
books I always get really excited
whenever they include things like sir
pounce he's a big part of Tommen's
character and as much as I disagree with
them aging him up so much
adding sir pounce back in was icing on
the cake this was also in that same
episode where they gave us lands of
always winter so I felt like the episode
in general was a big hat tip to book
readers from what Michelle Maclaren the
director of the episode said we're not
gonna see sir pounce again but that
doesn't mean that he won't be referenced
because they chose to include sir pounce
with Tom and scenes this season I'm
hoping that means that when we get
Shireen next season we get to see patch
face just because he is important to her
character and Anna did have a pretty
okay track record with including little
things from the books whenever it's
important for characters backstories
number four the lands of always winter
this was another one of those minor
controversies just because some book
readers felt like it was spoilers for a
winds of winter and there was the whole
thing about the HBO website spoiling the
night's king regardless of what you
thought about it or whether or not you
thought the night's King ding was
spoilery I was just amazed that they
even tried to do it based on what Dan
and Dave said about it after the fact
they said that they were just trying to
show something that was going on in the
book story at that moment but wasn't
something that George r Martin chose to
include in the books so another example
of that would be like if the show
decided to show us Stannis getting his
army and sailing to the wall they didn't
do that but it was happening in the
books it was going on but you don't read
about it in excruciating detail Tycho
andesaurus is just like here's a giant
bag of money grab everyone and get your
ass to the wall you better pay this back
because they said they'd be doing
additive scenes like this even more in
season 5 I think one of my bonus videos
is going to be for like little things in
the books that we hope we see on the
show like things that George R Martin
didn't write about but things that were
happening with regards to the White
Walkers I feel like they're just massing
their forces and slowly moving towards
the wall so hopefully in season 5 will
see another epic shot of their army I
know a lot of you are hoping to see some
giant White Walkers but I don't think
that's going to happen
though I do think they could reanimate
one of their corpses number three the
Battle of Craster's keep another big
change from the books but something that
was necessary to tie up old plot lines
I love the death they gave to burn
gorman I was such a fan of his on
Torchwood that seeing him play a crazy
villain was so much fun there were a few
big questions about the way the story
played out there like you know why
didn't bran just war Hodor earlier and
make him hook out on everyone I wasn't a
huge fan of the Locke character either
but they had to resolve his story
somehow and Craster's seemed like a good
enough time as any too bad they couldn't
have postponed his death - the wildling
attack it would have been fun to see him
get killed by that huge arrow that giant
fired or accidentally kill him with that
big scythe or maybe they could have sent
him into the tunnel with Grenda giant
slayer may he rest in peace on two more
battles number two Oberyn Martell vs.
the mountain this is one of the big book
scenes that they remain pretty faithful
to they did alter Oberyn just a little
bit in the book he was just a little bit
happier when he was dying just knowing
that he had poisoned the mountain but
the important parts were taken right off
the page like his speech trying to goad
the confession out of him
I saw behind-the-scenes video with Pedro
Pascal learning the fight choreography
so I think he did most of the fighting
himself which is amazing fight scenes
are hard to do period but fighting with
weapons like they did in that scene is
almost impossible especially if you're
not an expert so it was like the best
fight scene of the season and one of the
best film fight scenes like I really
enjoyed Brienne versus the Hound but I
felt like the way they filmed that was
just a little too much shakey cam so it
took me a little out of it and finally
my number one moment from season four is
actually a tie between re going to
Braavos and tear and killing Shae and
Tywin are you heading to Braavos is such
a huge turning point though for her
character and it's the start of her
story book for like a whole new books
worth of content I think that's part of
the reason they chose that to be the
final scene I maintained the fire and
ice' theme of the ending each season
just on the basis that she's a stark of
Winterfell it was such a huge point of
departure first story and it's a huge
transition for the show Stan this is at
the wall and taking white Walker
seriously Tyrion gives the middle finger
to everyone in King's Landing and hits
the road it's like characters on the
show transitioning from high school to
college or university if you're
International Tyrians ending felt like
it should have been more cathartic but I
think he's going to find the
killing Shay and Tywin isn't going to
lessen like any of his emotional burdens
the relief of those revenge kills is
always really short-lived it's never
100% solution to all your problems even
though it feels really good at the time
I don't know from personal experience
I'm just extrapolating from what the
characters are doing on screen time once
final moments were interesting for a
number of reasons there's that big
debate about whether or not he was being
truthful when he said he never intended
to let Tyrion die I chose to believe him
the first time I watched the episode he
definitely holds back a lot of
information but I don't think I've ever
seen him outright lied to someone at
least to their face he did admit that he
quietly took every opportunity to let
Tyrion die over the years so he kind of
contradicts himself I think it just
means that you can take him either way
you would be equally ride saying Tywin
was going to execute Tyrion or he was
going to save him
it's like Schrodinger's toilet you know
until he takes that dump both choices
are valid since there are like a billion
other huge moments let me know what your
favorites were and if you want to talk
about spoilery things that you want them
to include from the books next season
please just use the spoiler tags in the
comments so here's my big explanation on
doing full-on spoiler videos and stuff
for the book because I know a lot of you
guys have been asking for that stuff
I want to make content that you guys
asked for so if the majority of you
asked for something specific I'm gonna
do everything I can to make it happen
the reason I don't do spoilers all the
time is because making two videos for
one thing is just way too much I already
feel like during the season when I'm
doing more Game of Thrones than normal
I'm not able to do as many other videos
for other things as I like so adding
another video on top of that is just a
little too much because the season is
over now and we're into season 5 stuff
what I'm gonna try and do is just
designate portions of my videos for
spoilers in addition I will be doing
exclusive book videos like videos for
just stuff that's inside the books like
whenever we're just talking about
prophecies or theories like patch face
you know various with Blackfyre as well
as the three has the dragon stuff like
that like that's just book stuff and
because you guys have been so awesome
this season my next video is going to be
a book video it's gonna be about Aegon
the conquerer I'll post that on Sunday
be sure to subscribe to get it
I'm really proud of the way you guys
have completely embraced the use of
spoiler tags in the comments because you
guys have largely been really good about
the way you comment it hasn't been a
problem here thank you so much for
that you have no idea how much of a
problem it was whenever I was doing
videos for season three I will say you
can make any comment you want about
anything on any of my videos as long as
you're not committing a hate crime or
trolling someone the only reason I make
videos is just to communicate with
people just to talk about something that
we both really love so the more you guys
comment the happier I am I'm gonna be
doing a special personal QA during
VidCon so if you want to start asking me
personal questions for that
feel free I'll try to answer way more
than the usual ten or twenty in the
video and a lot of them I'll just answer
in the comments section I'm doing a
separate video in a couple days that
will explain all that better but right
now click here for my season 5
predictions and click here for my finale
Q&A thanks so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives